ايام قليله وتكمل استراتيجيه السعوديه
للنقل والخدمات اللوجستيه عامها الثاني
بعد اطلاقها في الثلاثين من يونيو 20 21
اطلاق ناقل جديد كان من ابرز اهداف
الاستراتيجيه وقد تحقق باطلاق طيران
الرياض الذي سيبدا نشاطه التجاري في العام
20/25
تستهدف الاستراتيجيه الى التوسع في
الوجهات الى
250 وجهه عالميه هذا التوسع يعني خصخصه
المطارات وهو ما حدث ويحدث في 25 مطارا في
جميع المناطق من خلال الشركات القابضه
التي تتولى تشغيلها
330 مليون مسافر سنويا رقم تريد السعوديه
تحقيقه بحلول العام 20 30
وسط تسارع لانجاز المشروع الاضخم في قطاع
النقل الجوي مطار الملك سلمان الذي وصفه
وزير النقل السعودي بانه سيمثل ثوره في
عالم المطارات الامير محمد بن سلمان قال
ان استراتيجيه النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه
ستمكن السعوديه من استغلالي موقعها
الجغرافي وتعزيز القدرات البشريه والفنيه
في القطاع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات